no matter Bob well out here is an
all-skate duck in 1923 CR 397 five-yard
ocular lenses that on June 24th 2020 mr.
attitude mr. Godsey was a fugitive from
justice pirated the president discommode
to be charged with having committed a
crime to wit the edge of homicide seven
cuts in another state to it the action
under pursuance investors General
Services section 28b please what a drug
to be absurd attorney Frank would you
accept this appointment
Mike where it actually comes out of
Boston I need no appointment for this
book all right so that will be please
winter and tumble any requests thank
your honor preference for the
Commonwealth we are asking the defendant
be held without writing until return to
authorities for the state of New
Hampshire speaking with attorney Frank
he's indicated that the defendant
intends to waive his right to rendition
we do have authorities today here in the
state of New Hampshire would be able to
take him immediately apartment his
signatures your honor
that's all correct your honor there's
one point I'd like to just put on the
record he is attending wave today I have
spoken through the New Hampshire law
enforcement people who are
today I represent him now I will
represent him until he gets new but turn
a new attorney to point to school in New
Hampshire then I've asked that they not
interrogate him without going through me
whether he gives permission or not all
right so then assert you've got the
right to require a mysterious lieutenant
governor's who are to return you to that
state the state of New Hampshire would
have to present evidence to a court to
establish that they have probable cause
to believe they were the person who
committed the crime in that state
understanding that you have these rights
do you wish to waive your rights to
interstate rendition proceedings in
return to the state of New Hampshire are
you doing this freely willingly involved
error yes
so now at this point in time the
defendant would have to sign the three
forms that the clerk's office has
created
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. Zhukovsky I realized can razor I
have reduced further from the difference
you have given the court of Madinah
hearing has been the truth to all truth
and nothing but the truth it's other guy
[Music]
all right so it's our new friend music
my understanding that your client is
typically this identification that
usually party that's it thank you in
there's one times if cancer officials to
approach
[Music]
this is attorneys burrows governor if
all the paperwork is in order to come
well for Philomel cross as a defendant
being taken into custody by New
Hampshire authorities farewell and
taking in custody by the authorities
comma was elected in this business
[Music]
nothing my name is John McCormick I'm
the COAS County Attorney here to inform
you that mr. Vladimir's ooh coughs key
of West Springfield Massachusetts was
formally charged with seven counts of
negligent homicide this morning in the
COAS Superior Court he waived
arraignment in appearance he's being
held on a detention order at this point
at the COAS County House of Corrections
with that said I'd be happy to take a
few brief questions from you all at this
point there's still an ongoing
investigation although he has been
charged at this point I can't really
send you more information than that at
this point again this was a very complex
crash scene a complex collision
involving multiple motorists who
incidentally the county attorney and
officer County Attorney in the entire
state is grieving for this loss it was a
complex situation and we wanted to make
sure that it developed before we made
any rash decisions and we wanted to make
sure we had probable cause as many of
you know Mike Ferrazzi was a deputy
sheriff that worked for us he was
unfortunately killed in this accident
and I am the spokesperson for Mike's
family as you can imagine they are in in
deep sadness and mourning their father
grandfather husband was taken tragically
in this with the others
the Faraz family would like you all to
know and your listeners to know that
there is a heartfelt thanks to those
first responders who are out there
as you just heard the county attorneys
say this was very chaotic a very tragic
scene I personally know through
conversation there have been people that
are working day and night day after day
I personally spoke with the governor and
the attorney general's office who has
been extremely helpful to the Ferrazzi
family and keeping us in the loop on
what they can tell us and we are
grateful for that more importantly we
are grateful to all of those people who
had to investigate that horrific scene I
think you all can imagine how difficult
that is today me and my staff escorted
the Faraz family and many of the
survivors and other family members and
members of the motorcycle group up here
today the intention was to be part of
this hearing as part of their healing